[Music] And
I had this idea that by making something like this, my
sisters and I were successful. We didn't have to
buy games or anything
until poverty came and instead of buying, we
played
[Music] and my brother and I modified it. I
mean, if I made a game that was
n't good, it meant it needed modifications, it would be modified for me and I would modify
it. Surprises in  One day I was
accused of mortadella and cans of sardines, so I asked
Ibrahim what do you do with the cans? I expected that they were
selling them like some kids. He told me that I make toys out
of them. I told him what do you do with these toys? We play with them [
music]
Cans of mortadella and sardines. I mean, we bring them to the
waste that we don’t have.  Other than a pliers, a cutter, a hammer, and a
broken wire
[music] We
heard better and better. Now they need support. I mean, they
need support to develop their talent. I mean, now they are making ballet things. I knew how. Because we want to support them, we want to develop their talent, God willing. I
mean, they will become special individuals, and it is forbidden for this
talent to be lost.  I am in the camp
[Music] We
would love to be in the future. I am an engineer and a camper. I mean, no one
says this is a camp. Not that there are kids like this in a world who
make it. They have talent. I mean, if someone comes
and sees what you are doing
[Music]